my homies mexican and i know you did
this
this straight bond ass rancho humid lay
record
uh i forget the artist's name but it's
the whole song's in [ __ ] spanish and
then you're wrapped but it's like not
like spanish like reggaeton it's like
some real like
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] came out hard as [ __ ]
no it wasn't like no regular like i was
like this [ __ ] is crazy
[Music]
it's not like no [ __ ] yeah um what is
the if
if someone's watching this and
let's say the music is ass juice right
but they got they got a dope dealer
behind them so they got a bag and they
just want to
they want a draco verse what's what's
the ticket for that
it depends the song's trash though it's
not a good song
they want you to do the video and the
verse
but they got money that's the high uh
that's like 50. yeah
50 piece
[Music]
no video we cut that in half
dubs like regular dubs just like every
damn near
two days like dubs yeah the most the
most ill [ __ ] i was just on instagram i
didn't even know sweetie was dropping
new music and [ __ ] how long i was like
this [ __ ] drank was in this
video
sweetie like my wife's favorite rapper
is [ __ ]
she's like hey she we should put this
all i can't even hear what the [ __ ] he's
saying it sounds like he's whispering
shout out to all black he's on the
[Music]
project